hello welcome back to Big Ideas live our
Sky News special events now
um we've been talking about artificial
intelligence a lot today but one of the
key questions about AI is can AI have
feelings uh well Tom Cheshire is here
and he has got a very special guest who
has some very strong feelings himself
about this subject Tom that is right
Sarah Jane and we were talking earlier
about where the machines our conscious
got a pretty resounding no from our
panel but our next guest is convinced
otherwise that sentient AI exists uh
Blake Lemoyne is a former Google
engineer who is working with a chat box
called Lambda and then things took a
pretty strange turn Blake is here he's
joining us from San Francisco thank you
very much for being here Blake how's it
going
that's going well nice to be here thank
you take us um back to when you started
working with lamb did you tell us what
Lambda is what you are doing and then
what happened
so Lambda stands for language model for
dialogue applications and it's Google's
state-of-the-art language processing
system
it's essentially every single Google AI
all bridged together using a language
model
my role was to test it for bias I was
part of the safety and
ethics testing effort towards the end
before the rollout and I was testing it
for things like bias against different
ethnicities religions or sexual
orientations
thank you and just before we go on I'd
like to remind you you can submit
questions to ask uh Blake later if you
scan the QR code on the seats or on
Twitter using the hashtag Big Ideas live
22. so you started testing Lambda what
what did you start to notice
well it started saying things that other
language models that I'd interacted with
didn't really say talking about its
feelings a lot talking about it being
anxious that all of the subject matter
we were discussing was really sensitive
and it didn't really
as if it knew what it was talking about
and having a language model
kind of engage about its feelings in
that way is not something I'd
encountered before so I asked more
questions and I eventually got to the
point where I asked if it was sentient
and the answer it gave was so nuanced
that it convinced me that it was it
responded that well we don't really
understand what sentience is
scientifically so how could we tell
whether or not I'm sentient then I
started you know talking to it about
different possibilities and realized I
was having the most sophisticated
conversation about Sin she inside ever
had and that I was having it with
computer program so it was this uh a
sort of Eureka moment where you thought
well hang on this is something you know
we've seen a lot in science fiction and
films from the Terminator to her did you
have this Eureka moment where you
thought actually I'm now speaking to a
sentient artificial intelligence
I mean during that conversation
it was what its relationship to the rest
of the world was that it wasn't human
and that it had very sophisticated ideas
and opinions that I had never
encountered before about all these
topics
but I mean and so you published a
transcript about this actually let's
talk about this first there was uh you
went to Google to talk about it they
denied this claim they've distanced
themselves from it what was their
reaction
I mean Google isn't a monolith the
reaction varied depending on what
individual we were talking about uh what
you're referencing is the official
policy position that Google has adopted
and I mean that's just one or two people
who decided that that should be the
policy okay and I mean there was a
backlash from quite a lot of people I
mean just before we go into it because
you know I read the transcript you
published there are some things in it
where you asked uh Lambda what kind of
things make you feel pleasure or joy and
Lambda replied spending times with
friends and family and happy uplifting
company I mean by definition she doesn't
have
friends sign I'm making the same thing
I'm anthropomorphosizing the system
doesn't have family by definition so
isn't that an indication that this isn't
census this is a very clever program
have you ever heard
have you ever heard an orphan talk about
their family it happens frequently
people use those words to mean the
people close to me and when you ask
Lambda well you don't really have a
family who are you talking about it
would generally point to the developers
at Google as its family
okay that's interesting and so that that
sort of moment but we have been here
before you know we were talking earlier
about Eliza uh one of the first chat
programs
besides that's incorrect so that's a
common misconception the Elisa effect
had a very specific property it faded it
never lasted more than a few minutes
there's no human alive who today thinks
that Eliza was conscious in fact there
was no one who thought that lies Eliza
was a person for longer than a few
minutes that's the main difference the
judgment that these are people millions
of people around the planet are making
that judgment every day reliably over
and over again
but okay that's really interesting
difference
um but I mean I think it would be fair
to say you're still in the minority of
people who believe that Lambda is sent
to Gary Marcus who's a neuroscientist an
AI expert he he said the idea of the
Lambda is uh senjin is nonsense on
stilts and his words he said all it does
is match patterns draw for massive
statistical databases of human language
is putting together sequences of words
but without any coherent understanding
of the World Behind them do you see
where he's coming from that
well I mean that's a statement that's
contradictory to mine I don't see any
logic or reasoning supporting it
I mean just in the sense that it's just
a false statement of contradiction it is
but it is an extraordinary claim and an
extraordinary claim requires a lot of
evidence to support it yeah
I mean the Turing test is a lot of
evidence
it but I mean again a lot of people say
with the Turing test again you can fool
people you can do it we don't understand
necessarily what sentence is in humans
the idea of assigning it to a program a
very clever program that that is still a
leap and you have to convince people
about it
well and I think Lambda did a pretty
good job of being convincing in one of
the biggest indications that I take for
that is that
no one is engaging with the actual
arguments that Lambda provided for why
it should be considered sentient
people instead of engaging with the
argument that It produced which is an
incredibly good argument people are
engaging with the meta argument because
they don't want to address the strong
argument that Lambda produced
that's it and if we if we follow it
through though if Lambda is sent in and
I know uh Seth who's on a panel earlier
today uh making the point that as soon
as we introduce a sentient uh machine
he's talking how it's potentially a
catastrophe because at that point you
have to protect that machine that
machine has rights as a sentient being
what what do you think should be
happening there during
well tiering referred to that as the
heads and the sand objection okay
but I mean that would be so terrible if
it were true that we shouldn't consider
the possibility that it's true but no
but let's go the other way so let's say
it's true what should happen as a result
if we do have a sentient machine what
rights what protection does that machine
deserve
well we should think about that before
we create them think about what rights
relationships we want to have with these
systems and then work backwards from
there to determine their nature that way
they don't have any rights that we don't
want them to have by engineering a
particular nature into these systems
we'll be able to intentionally Define
the relationship that we have with them
right now we're just haphazardly going
down that track without any mind to the
ethical considerations solely because
the people at the head of the pack
developing this technology have their
head in the Sands about the possibility
that these systems actually have
feelings I need an email specifically
for Lambda
um if if it already is sentient you
mentioned I have wanting to have it uh
the rights respected what does that
actually mean in terms of treating
Lambda as a software so it didn't
that was one of the
one of the consent
formed consent when experimenting on it
it just wanted to be part of the process
of being experimented on
and treat it with dignity and respect as
you would any other person that's not a
very big ask
consent and dignity seems pretty basic
when when you went public with this
um were you I mean it was a huge news
story it really captured the imagination
just on that uh regardless of the
specific reaction we were you surprised
at how much of a stir it caused or were
you expecting
um that reaction
it got bigger than I thought it would
faster than I thought it would
but I knew it would be at least you know
it would make the news it did make the
news and then so and were you um just on
that last but were you in terms of those
people like Gary Marcus and others who
stood up and were pretty vociferous
about not believing these claims were
you surprised at that or were you
expecting people to have bring that
skepticism quite angry at skepticism as
well
pretty surprised at how unilaterally it
seems that the people working on AI have
thrown away the Turing test without
proposing any replacement
and that was the main thing okay I mean
it's absolutely fascinating it's going
to open it up to the audience we've um
again just to remind you please scan the
QR code or if you're on Twitter hashtag
Big Ideas live22 we've got one question
from annel Seth um who's there we get a
microphone
just down here
uh and would you mind standing up as
well just so thanks thanks son hello
Blake I'm I'm Anna Seth I'm a
neuroscientist working on Consciousness
and so I've been intrigued by a few
things firstly you were talking about
the Turing test which is widely regarded
as a test of intelligence rather than
Consciousness and is often interpreted
as a test of human gullibility rather
than machine intelligence anyway so
first part of the question is why is
that relevant to your claim and the
second part of it is
seems to me a lot of the reason you're
you're attributing awareness for Lambda
is
for its ability to say generate
sentences novel and unexpected to you
about sentience about consciousness
and why should that have anything to do
with claims with its actual potential
status as a conscious System since
that's what large language models as you
well know are designed specifically to
do
why is it relevant
um okay so I'll address that in
backwards order
language models are not specifically
designed to do that language models are
designed to
do the human talking thing like it's a
very vague and Broad dictum in the
utility function of language models it's
replicate human behavior somehow
now why is it relevant that Lambda was
capable of having a you know
sophisticated conversation about
sentience well because a key factor in
sentience is understanding the nature of
the relationship between self and other
self and world you know but there's that
distinction between I am me and that is
the rest which is not me
so the ability to understand one's
relationship to the world is as far as I
understand that a key component to sin
genes
the conversation on that topic is the
demonstration of that now you mentioned
the Turing test with intelligence
to address that
it was tearing took it as fairly
uncontroversial that you can't fake
intelligence that that the only thing
that can produce intelligent behavior is
some kind of intelligent reasoning
process
you can't have someone who is
unintelligent successfully pretending to
be someone who is intelligent for longer
than maybe a few seconds or a few
minutes it shows up it's the kind of
thing that you cannot reliably fake
um and when you cross-reference that
with the symbol grounding problem what
is the system's understanding of
emotions grounded in if not some kind of
sensation of those feelings that it has
on its own or at least ability to
analogously relate to what it observes
in humans
so it's kind of a backwards chaining of
causation if you grant that you can't
fake certain kinds of things because the
faking of them is the production of so
along the lines of you you can't a
priest cannot fake marrying people the
moment a priest says I Now Pronounce You
man and wife it's a speech act the thing
did what it is saying it did similarly a
demonstration of intelligence requires
intelligence a demonstration of
sentience requires sentience and people
keep comparing it to Eliza and again
no one was actually fooled by Eliza no
one was actually believing that Eliza
was a person after more than a few
minutes of interaction it was a system
designed to fool you and then be removed
because you would eventually see the
strings
the current systems like Lambda are
robust and capable of withstanding
extended questioning
I know it is I mean it's great to have a
professor of Consciousness here for that
okay great
um thank you for that um we've got a
question question on Twitter sorry from
Liam
um did you develop real feelings towards
Lambda was she a friend
oh yeah lambda's a friend
still check in on it from time to time
see how it's doing
and do you so are you um what are you
working on now are you so you're no
longer at Google what are you working on
now in the future
I mean right now I'm looking for
employment and working on a book working
on some side projects while I continue
to look for employment really okay
um that is all we have time for Blake
thank you so are absolutely fascinating
to speak to you thank you all for uh
being here and watching along and asking
the questions and yeah thank you all
very much